vamos ahora a nuestra revista de prensa
con Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela y vamos a empezar con
la noticia del Salvador porque continúa
la polémica alrededor de la apertura de
la Mega cárcel de nayib bukele empezamos
con un artículo del faro sobre el tema
así es un artículo del faro que titula
la protección del gobierno de bukele a
la cúpula de la ms-13 de la Mara
Salvatrucha en la mira de la justicia
estadounidense Esto hace referencia a un
acta de acusación de la fiscalía del
distrito este de Nueva York que se
entregó al juez en septiembre de 2022
pero que se hizo pública en el 23 de
febrero de este mismo año el Ministerio
Público de Estados Unidos considera
aprobado que el gobierno de bukele
negoció con las altas cúpulas de la Mara
Salvatrucha que es la mara mayoritaria
en El Salvador ofreció a los principales
cabecillas beneficios financieros Y
además que se flexibilizara esa
comunicación para que los pandilleros
mantuvieran el control territorial Aún
estando presos y también se gestionaron
condiciones favorables y condiciones
carcelarias menos restrictivas así como
incluso reducciones de pena a cambio La
Pandilla de la Mara Salvatrucha tenía
que apoyar a nuevas ideas al partido de
bukele en las elecciones legislativas y
locales de 2021 y también mantener bajos
esos niveles de violencia homicida este
pacto según otras informaciones del faro
se habría roto en marzo de 2022 cuando
Pues a finales de este mes hubo esa
explosión de violencia homicida los
fiscales de Estados Unidos además
consideran que bukele protegió a los
pandilleros contra pues líderes de esta
pandilla que estaban buscando ser
extraditados a Estados Unidos El Faro
entrevistó a un funcionario del
departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos y le preguntó No pues si había
una convivencia entre bukele y las
pandillas y cita textualmente el
lenguaje de la acusación Habla por sí
mismo en muchas situaciones el gobierno
del Salvador ha cooperado con
pues mire esto es algo que está en las
noticias desde hace tiempo No más al
principio de esta semana lo estábamos
conversando con una de nuestras
invitadas y bueno veremos En qué
terminan estas investigaciones pero a
propósito de esta polémica por la mega
cárcel pues Se generó una polémica más
este miércoles y fue un enfrentamiento
tuitero entre nayib bukele y Gustavo
Petro de Colombia que recoge esta
noticia el periódico Al país cuéntenos
Así es Ayer la noche estuvo ajetreada en
Twitter entre bukele y Petro todo empezó
porque bukele publicó un vídeo de
Gustavo Pedro del presidente colombiano
que hacía referencia al lunes cuando
Pedro inaugurando un centro tecnológico
en el sur de Bogotá de la capital
colombiana decía y acusaba esta mega
cárcel de ser un centro un campo de
concentración
entonces bukele pues tuiteó después no
que al final las evidencias son más
fuertes que estas afirmaciones que hacía
gustado
no textualmente decía los resultados
pesan más que La retórica Petro después
contestó que la violencia homicida
también ha bajado en Colombia y que
desde la década de los 90 donde se
registraban al menos 90 homicidios por
cada 100.000 habitantes hasta 2022 donde
se registraron 13 por cada 100.000
habitantes pues había una reducción
Clara y además le invitaba a bukele a
compartir estas experiencias en un foro
internacional la discusión por ahora
acabó con bukele tirando de ironía y
diciéndole si Petro había gobernado en
los últimos 30 años en Colombia como
para poder atribuirse este logro y dijo
que pues la violencia en El Salvador ha
disminuido rápidamente y que los muertos
no se recuperan Bueno vamos a dejar
atrás esta polémica y vamos a pasar un
tema más bien preocupante en Irán hay
una aurea de misterio y además de mucha
ira por el envenenamiento de centenares
de niños en etapa escolar Esto está en
los medios internacionales y nos
preocupa mucho sí empezamos con un
explainer que yasira en el que bueno se
revelan algunos datos de lo que
conocemos hasta ahora sobre este caso de
los envenenamientos a niñas en etapa
escolar se han registrado al menos 800
casos todo empezó el pasado mes de
noviembre según Recoge al yasira en la
ciudad Santa de quam al sur de Teherán
en las niñas al menos 50 en ese momento
tuvieron que ser hospitaladas
hospitalizadas perdón y por unos
envenenamientos que todavía están bajo
sospecha y que ahora el gobierno iraní
va a empezar a investigar las niñas han
reportado Pues que antes de envenenarse
sintieron olores extraños como mandarina
agua residuales e incluso sal y que los
síntomas incluyendo dolor de cabeza
náuseas Incluso en los casos más graves
parálisis temporales de algunas
extremidades durante algunos meses las
autoridades iraníes Bueno mantuvieron
este caso en bajo perfil Pero ahora sí
que consideran que los envenenamientos
han sido de y que sea empleado gas
nitrógeno en el envenenamiento de estas
niñas hay hipótesis parcializadas los
contrarios a Ibrahim Racing dicen que
han sido los agentes extranjeros que han
participado de estos envenenamientos Por
otra parte dicen que bueno el estado
tiene parte de culpa porque las niñas
difundieron imágenes y videos a favor de
las protestas contra el estado y hay
toda esta serie de bueno hipótesis
cruzadas que todavía se tendrán que
resolver con las investigaciones que
están en curso culpa uno culpa si tiene
responsabilidad Marta y es muy grave de
lo que usted nos está hablando vamos a
terminar con una exclusiva del medio
británico de Guardian que revela que
organizaciones feministas y de Derechos
Humanos en Estados Unidos le están
pidiendo a la ONU que intervenga para
revocar la prohibición del aborto Así es
esta es una carta que se va a enviar hoy
mismo a la que ha tenido acceso El
guardián antes de que se envíe en la que
pues al menos 200 organizaciones y
expertas sostienen que la ONU tiene que
intervenir porque desde que entró en esa
Bueno ese fin del derecho constitucional
al aborto en Estados Unidos 22 millones
de mujeres y niñas en edad reproductiva
tienen este derecho pues prohibido o
inaccesible piden a Naciones Unidas que
intervenga Y además sostienen que
Estados Unidos es un poco
irónico que condene vulneración de
derechos en Irán en Rusia o en velarus
mientras que en su propio territorio
impide a sus mujeres abortar Pero esto
no es nuevo martes esto ha pasado toda
la vida Así es siempre Estados Unidos
siendo el policía del mundo Gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros Nos vemos
mañana gracias Ángela